yeah because out of all the Disney
properties that people seem to love the
most
it was Pocahontas clearly we needed a
sequel to that truth be told I don't
know what's more shocking the fact that
they actually made a sequel to this film
that was so historically inaccurate and
the majority of audiences didn't like
and even then he said was the beginning
of the downfall of hand-drawn Disney
animation
or the fact that I can't believe I'm
saying this I actually enjoyed this one
a little bit more than the original but
if you know what I think of the original
that's not saying much it's still not
good in fact they're a scene start
downright cringe-worthy to sit through
but again as I'm finding out with some
of these Disney sequels there was a
legitimate talent going in that I have
to admire on some levels sort of the
film opens up as stupid as you think a
movie called Pocahontas too would open
up John Smith is up airlie killed by the
villain from the last film Ratcliffe
somehow through some very confusing
exposition especially for a kid's film
this means that the white man can go and
invade Pocahontas is tried but one man
named John Rolfe played by Billy Zane
believes this is unfair so he pleads
with the King to talk to the chief and
see if they can work out something
between the two the chief is resistant
though especially seeing how the
settlers on their land are not always
the best just wait until what happens in
the future
Pocahontas his daughter offers to go in
his place Rolfe begrudgingly agrees but
thinks there's still some way to turn
this into something positive even if
he's not getting the chief himself
Pocahontas is thus introduced to a new
world and finds out that she's going to
make any progress she has to adapt but
she learns their etiquette their way of
doing things and of course put on a
pretty dress that they can mark it to
all the Disney princess line let's see
where is it there she is
it's a border line of my fair lady story
but keeps just interesting enough that
doesn't become too clichéd and she does
a good job winning the people over
showing that they're not all just
savages and that they can in fact be
very intelligent and very peaceful but
when wreckless brings in a bear to
torture as apparently this was some sort
of entertainment in the day I'm not sure
if that's true but if we allowed
bullfighting as anything's possible
Pocahontas stands up for the poor
creature is up driving the King insane
for some reason orders her to be thrown
in jail on the attack
her people to begin and we go right back
into stupid territory again with sword
fights John Smith returning a romance
blooming even though apparently the
person she found what was before doesn't
count anymore even though he was kinda
still interested but not but it's okay
because her is the capable strong hero
is suddenly seen doing very little in
terms of saving the day all of a sudden
it gets so stupid there's an immense
tragedy with this film because unlike
the first one I didn't always know where
it was going and the way was written and
the way was animated and the way it was
paid it was surprisingly kind of
engaging with the first film I knew
every second every line every character
what was going to happen it was so
predictable you knew the exact message
plot when things were going to happen it
was just ridiculous the only thing you
really had going for was a good color
scheme and some nice music here the
color scheme and music aren't quite as
good obviously with the budget cuts but
there is still a lot of artistic merit
not only some of the scenery really nice
and by god I forgot what a good singer
the voice actress of Pocahontas is but I
felt the expressions in this were much
stronger than the last one in fact a lot
of scenes of pointless dialogue are
taken out just replaced by how they look
look at this scene where Pocahontas
saying goodbye to her best friend they
barely say a thing but look at that look
at the emotion in their faces
it's remarkable there's another great
scene where she first sees the King and
she freezes they never explain why they
never talked about it but you just feel
the moment and it's a quiet scene
there's not a lot of in-your-face music
it can actually be very subtle there's a
real conflict between how much of
Pocahontas culture does she give up to a
death and how much does she hold on to
what does she sacrifice for the greater
good
that's ten times more interesting than
what we got in the last film where you
knew from begin to end what was going to
happen I really hated how at the end of
the last film she didn't go to the New
World she just stayed with her people
and I thought why why are you closing
those possibilities why are you just
keeping things separate but in this one
you do see the lands explored you see
how she reacts to things and it's
interesting and it's charming and the
romance is nice and the full side
character that's following her around
trying to protect her he's cool I like
how all the people don't know how to
after but they don't immediately shun
her they're just curious they're unsure
and I don't know it just felt more
relatable it felt more interesting which
is both surprising but also a shame that
it started off so terrible and it ends
so terrible I've never seen a movie
where the middle was the best part again
for what these people had to make and
what could have so easily been a
phoned-in project I really felt they
were trying it just didn't work whether
it be because of notes from Disney or
they just made the wrong choices or they
didn't think the thing all the way
through but yeah to its credit there
were much more moments where I was
sucked in with Pocahontas too than I was
with the first one so I guess if you're
really interested in checking out I
would probably say just best forward to
where she's going to the new world and
then stop at where they're torturing the
bear because anything outside of that is
garbage but for some strange reason the
middle part of this movie is actually
pretty strong okay it's not perfect but
it's Pocahontas - I was thoroughly
impressed I got anything interesting at
all so I guess I'm glad some parts of it
worked hell actually a good chunk of it
worked but it still doesn't work as a
complete whole and that does really
damage it the bad scenes aren't just bad
they're embarrassingly bad if you're
curious it's not creatively bankrupt
actually I'm glad I saw this movie or at
least the middle anyway but the rest of
the colors of the wind sadly are blowing
me away
[Music]
you